[Musique]
clément bonne secrétaire d'état chargé
des affaires européennes s'est rendu à
l'université de la réunion afin
d'assister à la rentrée des étudiants
internationaux sur le campus ils sont 6
137 représentant 60 nationalités
différentes tous ont fait le choix de
poursuivre leur cursus universitaire à
la réunion je voulais améliorer mon
français parce que ça fait j'ai grandi
bilingue mais après après mes 9 ans j'ai
arrêté de parler donc je voulais
reprendre un peu
et après aussi je serai en train de
mentir si le paysage les plages le
climat m'a tirée par un peu aussi et
surtout j'ai fait des études
d'environnement et de conservation de la
biodiversité et la réunion fait partie
d'un hotspot de biodiversité des îles de
masquer des mascareignes donc cela
m'intéresse vachement aussi et c'est
toute cette nomination de choses de
motivation fait des études de droit et
donc je voulais en gros avoir une
impression du droit français et après la
réunion parce qu'il ya des choses qui
change par rapport à la france
métropolitaine c'est aussi pour la
culture et la nature
voilà pour connaître les territoires
d'outre-mer de la france une centaine
d'entre eux est issu du programme
erasmus un programme des changes qui
favorisent la mobilité étudiante dans
l'enseignement supérieur en europe
beaucoup d'étudiants erasmus il ya un
engagement ici à l'université de st
venait de s'ouvrir à la mobilité
européenne internationale et c'est pas
seulement je crois anecdotique c'est un
symbole de l'ouverture de la réunion
c'est un symbole aussi le ce que
l'europe est capable de faire de concret
utile pour cette génération de jeunes en
particulier ceux qui font erasmus s'en
souviendront toute leur vie ces
étudiants en fait peuvent être aussi des
ambassadeurs de l'arrêt non ça permet
l'attractivité du territoire et je pense
aussi que ça permet de nourrir de
véritables échanges de pouvoir montrer
aussi aux réunionnais l'exemple de
pouvoir voyager et ça ouvre je crois que
le voyage ça ouvre l'esprit et ça donne
l'occasion d'élargir ses champs le
secrétaire d'état a participé à la pose
de la première pierre du futur pôle de
traitement et de valorisation des
déchets des territoires sud et ouest
située à pierrefonds rené va sera
opérationnel fin 2023 pour un budget
total de 235 millions d'euros il y a eu
un soutien de l'europe de plus de 20
millions d'euros et un soutien
significatif aussi de l'état et de
l'ademe voilà et donc je crois que si on
met bout à bout les prêts les
subventions qui ont été données par
l'êta par l'europe en complément bien
sûr de ce qu'on fait les collectivités
locales on a financement très
significatif moi je voulais signaler que
cette part de l'europe elle n'est pas
anecdotique parfois on la met pas en
avant et c'est ça qui permet souvent de
boucler un projet qui me si les
collectivités locales est de sortir
l'état rené va permettra de recycler
plus de trente trois mille tonnes de
déchets supplémentaires et surtout de
valoriser sous forme d'énergie
électrique les déchets non recyclables
[Musique]